les mauves parisiens peuvent laisser
éclater leur joie ils viennent
d'engranger leur deuxième victoire en
deux matches dans le championnat de r3
pourtant rien n'a été simple pour le
produit dans cette rencontre
bousculés à deux partout ils prennent
les devants avec ce troisième but sur ce
penalty 3-2 à cinq minutes de la fin à
maurepas conseils à son tour un penalty
mais le gardien antoine baptiste surgit
pour sauver son équipe
score final 3 à 2 le tireur freddy
ralenti sa course
je pense qu'il a essayé de me madické
deux mois durant d'erreurs bon après je
pars du bon côté j'ai la chance de
sortir
il n'est pas très très bien tiré mais
j'ai la chance de sortir le classico là
on a un grand antoine qui nous sort le
penalty
même si ça arrive sur les 10-15
dernières secondes voire vraiment la fin
du match mais ça a fait ça a fait un
grand bien à l'équipe et ça nous a
permis d'aller chercher ensuite sa
victoire cette deuxième victoire de la
saison propulse eu les mots repasser en
tête du classement de cette poule d avec
6 points et surtout sept buts marqués en
deux matches l'objectif de base c'est
comme toute l'équipe qui monte c'est le
maintien
maintenant nous on se refuse à rien on a
fait deux matches deux victoires
si on peut aller chercher au moins le
haut de tableau la première partie 2 du
tableau ça sera sera déjà bien
mais je fais pas je vais pas vous dire
qu'on veut monter mes 6 ans se présente
pourquoi pas pour continuer à croire à
une place dans le haut du classement
maurepas ira défier le dimanche 11
octobre l'équipe 2 de versailles
objectif réaliser un trois sur trois en
ce début de championnat